our journalism experts blew it yet again
on a major story targeting president
trump
dr anthony fauci declares that attacks
on him are attacks on science
and even the white house is now
disappointed in kamal harris i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your data is your business
protected
expressvpn.com slash ben we'll get to
all the news in just a moment first your
reminder you're paying way too much for
your cell phone bill i know you haven't
thought about that in a while but that
is the reality which is why thousands of
my
faithful listeners have already switched
over to pure talk usa
and you should as well what exactly are
you waiting for if you're with a t
verizon or t-mobile your family could
save over 800
a year just by switching to pure talk
you get the same great coverage because
they use the exact same towers as one of
the big carriers you can even keep your
phone
and your number but you will save a
fortune by the way puretalk is the
absolute top-rated wireless company by
consumer affairs they've got the best
customer service team based right here
in america
and it gets even better because right
now you get unlimited talk unlimited
text
and six gigs of data for 30 bucks a
month which is a really really good
price
and you're saying yourself wait hold on
six gigs a month
i'm gonna go over on that probably well
here's the thing if you do they're not
gonna charge you for it you have nothing
to lose
grab your mobile phone dial pound 250
say ben shapiro to get started today
when you do you say fifty percent off
your very first month now pound two five
zero
say keyword ben shapiro to get started
and start saving yourself
hundreds of bucks on your cell phone
coverage pure talk is simply
smarter wireless alrighty so another day
another media narrative that has
completely imploded about president
trump so
what are we up to now and we've had the
the entire four year long saga of how
trump was a russian caspar and that
turned out to be absolute nonsense
and we've had president trump as the
as the scourge of the of all
living human beings all over the planet
for a variety of reasons usually those
stories fall apart we've had
a bunch of sub stories along these lines
okay here's the latest the latest
is the media completely blew it on one
of the biggest talking points that
democrats used
in 2020. that talking point because they
wanted to distract from the blm riots
was that donald trump had cleared
a bunch of protesters peaceful
protesters in
lafayette park in order so that he could
have a photo op in front of a burnt out
church
okay now that talking point was always
pretty dubious because
the park police themselves had said at
the time guys we were clearing the park
because people were getting violent at
the time
that didn't stop folks from tweeting out
about the evils of president trump
clearing the park so we have like a
bunch of tweets from all these people
who push this false narrative for
example npr politics
tweeted out that day this is june 1st
2020 police in washington dc used tear
gas and rubber bullets on peaceful
protesters to clear them away from saint
john's church which suffered a small
fire sunday night near the white house
president trump then walked to the
church for a photo op
this was the way the media covered it
joe biden who was then running for
office wasn't president
of the united states yet he tweeted out
he's using the american military against
the american people
he tear gas peaceful protesters and
fired rubber bullets for a photo
for our children for the very soul of
our country we must defeat him but i
mean it when i say this we can only do
it
together that was joe biden back in june
2020 kamal harris your current vice
president then candidate she said donald
trump
just tear-gassed peaceful protesters for
a photo op she did that on the basis of
a headline from huffington post that
said
as the president spoke police deployed
tear gas and flashbangs against
protesters outside the white house
demanding justice for george floyd
daniel dale the official cnn fact
checker
so many facts checked by daniel tale his
entire job
was just to fire hose a bunch of things
that donald trump
had said wrong now his job is to
downplay anything the democrats say that
is wrong
sort of tut them well back then he
tweeted out this is february of 2021
actually
he tweeted out vanderveen falsely claims
the clearing of lafayette square last
june
happened to establish an appropriate
security perimeter from a riot as mob
no they cleared peaceful protesters out
of the way for a trump photo op
the narrative the intervene is mocking
is correct that was testimony
that was being made about what happened
so daniel dale the official cnn fact
checker
getting it completely wrong because here
is the actual story there is an
inspector general
the inspector general for the interior
department and here is what they found
according to the washington post
when the u.s park police led law
enforcement officers into a crowd of
mostly peaceful protesters outside love
outside lafayette square on june 1st
2020 including officers equipped with
chemical irritants and officers on
horseback
they did so as part of a plan made days
earlier to build a fence around the park
to protect officers
not to facilitate the visit minutes
later by president trump to a nearby
church an inspector general's report
released wednesday concluded
the report also found that dc police
officers fired tear gas at protesters
as they moved away from the park toward
17th street the park police did not
deploy tear gas on june 1st but did on
previous days and bureau of prisons
officers fired pepper spray munitions
from the park without provocation during
the clearing
investigators also found that the audio
warnings issued by the park police
before the operation were not widely
heard by the crowd and mostly
ineffective
the report by the interior department's
inspector general focuses on the park
police
and does not fully address questions
about the involvement of other agencies
or the trump administration the events
of june 1st
interior officials said they may not
have heard all of the discussions that
went on about the operation within the
secret service or the white house
but that those discussions did not
affect how and when the park police
acted
the investigators did not interview
secret service or white house personnel
the report found that preparations to
clear the protesters and erect offense
began two days before the park clearing
two days but the idea may have gained
greater urgency on the morning of june
1st okay now they're just speculating
the washington post has previously
reported trump was furious at reporting
that revealed he had been taken to an
emergency bunker on the first night of
protests
the group agreed the park police and
supporting teams of law enforcement
officers would extend the perimeter and
gradually push protesters further away
from the white house and st john's
church which had been vandalized the
previous night
by midday trump was working with close
confidence on a plan to project his
control over the city by walking across
lafayette square but the
the this had nothing to do with what the
park police were doing the park police
have been planning for days to already
clear
lafayette square park police officials
including then-acting chief gregory
monahan
an unidentified incident commander told
inspector general investigators they
learned around mid to late afternoon
of the president's unscheduled movement
to lafayette park both park police
officials reported
they were not told a specific time for
the president's potential arrival and
that learning this information did not
change their operational timeline which
was to push protesters back as soon as
national guard officers and the fencing
arrived
both of which occurred after 5 pm
monahan told investigators quote i can
tell you with
100 certainty the secret service in the
park police timeline
did not change the entire day
okay so the entire media and the
democratic party ran with the lie
that donald trump forcibly cleared
lafayette park in order so that he could
have this photo op that that's what this
is about
instead park police cleared it because
they'd been planning to for days and as
it turns out by the way
there were a bunch of officers who had
been injured in lafayette park
over the prior couple of days there are
a bunch of officers
who there were 49 officer injuries
around lafayette park through may 31st
between may 25th and may 31st
49 officer injuries because park police
were according to the report being
pelted
with water bottles rocks and fireworks
but wait we were told these were
peaceful protesters just people who were
out there chanting for justice
and they were cleared because donald
trump evil donald trump
wanted to walk out and hold up a bible
at st john's church nobody could explain
how these peaceful protesters had burned
the church
five minutes beforehand but the entire
narrative was never very good
and then the media just played it to the
hilt this was part of campaign
commercials for the democrats this was
joe biden
talking about it openly on the campaign
trail it was kamala harris lying about
it on the campaign trail
and again the media just ran with this
thing they ran with it
because it was beneficial to their
narrative which is that donald trump was
a fascist
the narrative was not going to be good
for them if it turned out that they had
been fostering
and backing and supporting rioters who
had injured
49 police officers or had been or
contributed 49 injuries to police
officers
and then made excuses for those people
and blame trump that had been a worse
narrative
so instead it was donald trump evil nazi
fascist
clearing the park of peaceful
flower-powered children
oh except none of that was true except
that wasn't true
and we'll meet the press acknowledged
that yesterday it was very very awkward
here was the here was kenzalanian over
at nbc's meet the press
having to make the awkward announcement
that yeah we kind of blew this thing for
a year
it doesn't second guess the decision to
clear the protesters it says that the
park police was within their rights
and this is controversial chuck black
lives matter is suing the justice
department in federal court over this
and our own garrett hake was there that
day and and reported if you recall that
the protests were not violent at that
moment until the police
moved in and caused violence that was
his direct bird's eye reporting chuck so
this remains an issue of consciousness
is not the reality the narrative we
thought we knew is not the reality man
doesn't that sum up the entire
mainstream media for the past
30 years or so the narrative we thought
we knew is not reality
why did you think you knew that
narrative why didn't i mean the park
police said
at the time what the inspector general's
report ended up finding which is that
these two
events were not connected that trump may
have taken advantage of the fact that
park was cleared to go do the photo op
but that they did not clear the park
before the photo op
there's a difference okay but the
narrative we thought we knew
is not reality why did you think you
knew the narrative
why hmm could it be that you
manufactured the narrative because the
narrative is exactly what you wanted to
promulgate and by the way this was the
constant
drum beat it was the constant pattern
throughout the trump administration it's
the constant pattern today the
narratives that back the biden
administration are the ones they want to
manufacture
just like the narratives that that
undercut the trump administration those
were the narratives that they wanted to
push
as hard as they possibly could
everything from trump
backs white supremacists to trump is a
russian catspaw
all those narratives are unbased in fact
does not matter they've continued to
promote those narratives over and over
and over again
down to by the way the idea that donald
trump is responsible
for the riots of january 6th as though
the people who rioted didn't have agency
and ignoring the fact that he explicitly
called in his speech for
for people to be peaceful at the at the
capitol you could rip into trump's
rhetoric
without suggesting that he is
responsible for that any more than
bernie sanders is responsible
for a nutcase going and shooting up a
bunch of congressional baseball players
we'll get some more of the journalism
media's
falsity in just one second first let us
talk about the fact that if you have a
balance on your credit cards that is
growing you can absolutely bankrupt
yourself it is horrible for you you need
to get that cleaned up
right now the best way to do that head
on over to my friends over at
lightstream
right now you get a credit card
consolidation loan from lightstream with
rates
starting at just 5.95 apr with auto pay
and excellent credit
it's lower than your average credit card
interest rate which is over 19
apr the rate is fixed it's not going to
go up over the life of the loan you get
a loan anywhere from 5 000 bucks to 100
000 bucks with no fees no application
fees no origination fees no transaction
fees no prepayment penalties plus
you can even get your money in your bank
account as soon as the day you apply
lightstream believes that people with
good credit deserve a better loan
experience that is exactly
what they are delivering just for my
listeners right now apply now get a
special interest rate discount and save
even more
the only way to get that discount go to
lightstream.com shapiro that's l-i-g-h-t
s-t-r-e-a-m.com shapiro
subject to credit approval rates range
from 5.95 april to 19.99
apr includes 0.50 auto pay discount
lowest rate requires excellent credit
terms and conditions apply
offers are subject to change without
notice visit lightstream.com shapiro for
more information and to see
what they can do for you alrighty so
again
big narrative of last year donald trump
cleared the park of peaceful protesters
because he's a fascist this was by the
way exhibit a
this is one a in the trump is a fascist
case that the left was putting out there
he's such a fascist that he sends his
brown shirt goons to go clear a park
a flower power children and then take a
militant photo op standing in front of a
church holding a bible what a
fascist except it wasn't true the
narrative we thought we knew as
kenzalanian says
turns out not to comport with the
reality and that is
how many times are we going to have to
see this before you stop believing the
media at face value before you
wait 48 hours before believing whatever
headline they are telling you
another narrative of last year that has
now been thoroughly debunked
okay remember that time that donald
trump kept talking about
hydroxychloroquine
remember that time and the media went
nuts how dare he this giant orange
buffoon
mention hydroxychloroquine doesn't he
know about toscience
doesn't he know hydroxychloroquine
doesn't do anything
not only that but because donald trump
keeps saying hydroxychloroquine
some crazy lady in arizona fed her
husband fishtank cleaner and he died
now it turns out they may have been
murdered but doesn't matter the only
reason they did that is because trump
kept saying
hydroxychloroquine over and over and
over because hydroxychloric
is bad it's very bad okay now new study
out this week according to yahoo news
quote
a new study shows that the controversial
drug hydroxychloroquine first of all
the fact that it is titled the
controversial drug hydroxychloroquine
where did the controversy begin guys
seriously where did it begin it began
with you guys declaring that if trump
said anything it had to be false if
trump said wuhan lab leak it had to be
false and it was a conspiracy theory if
trump said hydroxychloroquine
is effective many doctors have said that
it is effective many doctors are
prescribing it
then it must be that it's false now by
the way we all knew
doctors were prescribing
hydroxychloroquine i know people
who got coveted and within the first
couple of days they got a hold of
hydroxychloroquine they took it with
azithromycin and zinc
and it did help their symptoms well now
a new study is backing this
okay there were studies both ways for
about a year and now it turns out a new
study suggests actually
a pretty significant effect with regard
to hydroxychloroquine when you take it
with the z-pack
the observational study published by med
rv rx iv
found that anti-malarial drug
hydroxychloroquine along with zinc
right this is what so many of these
studies were like if you just take
alone then it won't do any yes nobody
said it was going to do anything
everyone knew that the only studies that
mattered were going to be about
hydroxychloroquine
which is an immunosuppressant and zinc
okay along with zinc and zithromycin
in the observational study found that
hydroxychloroquine along with zinc could
increase the coronavirus survival rate
by as much as nearly 200
if distributed at higher doses to
ventilated patients with a severe
version of the illness
the study's conclusion says we found
that when the cumulative doses of two
drugs
hydroxychloroquine and zithromycin zinc
were above a certain level patients had
a survival rate
2.9 times the other patients
the study adds by using causal analysis
and considering the weight
and considering of weight adjusted
cumulative dose we provide the combined
therapy greatly increases survival in
covid patients
and that the more and that the
hydroxychloroquine cumulative dose
of more than 80 milligrams per kilogram
works substantially better
these data do not yet apply to
hospitalized patients not on imv
the study was conducted by saint
barnabas medical center in new jersey on
255 patients
now remember if you mentioned
hydroxychloroquine and you said that it
was good
you would actually get kicked off of
youtube
if you said hydroxychloroquine is
effective
you would get booted from facebook and
youtube and twitter and they would call
you a nut
why because the narrative we thought we
knew is not the fact
just the same way the woohen lab leak if
you mention that you get booted off
youtube
if you did not simply repeat the experts
you'd get booted don't trust people who
declare themselves experts without
showing you their work
if they don't show you their work they
are not true experts if they can't tell
you how they achieved a conclusion
you don't have to believe their
conclusion okay that is the
trust but verify okay but nobody adds
but verify as we'll see in just one
moment
because we have now entered a world and
this is this is true really since the
beginning of the 20th century when the
great intelligence of the west decided
that the rest of the world and
particularly people in their own
societies were a bunch of rubes hicks
and morons and that the experts had to
run everything
bureaucracies in the government had to
run everybody's life we needed experts
at all the major universities who were
going to
run things top down it was going to be
true in every institution the experts
were going to run things
in science it wasn't going to be the
process of science that was important
it was going to be tough science meaning
scientists personally
in journalism it wasn't the process of
journalism that mattered it was who was
deemed a journalist
this is why there's a big fight going on
right now about whether people like
james o'keefe are journalists
or whether outlets like daily wire or
journalistic
and the answer is if we are performing
active journalism then we have acted as
a journalist on that day
certainly better than nbc did for a year
on this particular story
yeah science most people tend to think
of other people's jobs in terms of like
titles but the reality is
that what makes you a doctor is act of
doctoring okay and what makes you a
scientist is acts of science and what
makes you a journalist is acts of
journalism and so we should be able to
assume that the only things of value in
those particular professions are when
you are performing the acts associated
with the title if you are not
your title does not mean anything so if
you declare yourself a journalist but
then you're jim acosta you're not a
journalist
unless you're performing in active
journalism you're not a journalist
you're just an opinion giver
if you want to be more accurate you can
call yourself an opinion journalist
that's fine because sometimes you do
opinion and sometimes you do journalism
but to pretend that journalism is a
title that is a crown set upon you by
heaven
and that from now on anything you say
will be deemed true whereas this guy
over here he's not a journalist because
he doesn't do the same things that i do
that's silliness and the same thing is
true in science as we'll see in just
one second first let's talk about the
fact that if you need a great night's
sleep
you need a great pillow it is that
simple let me tell you about my pillow
yes i have my pillow it's a great it's a
great product it really is fantastic my
wife and i were fighting over are my
pillow until we just ordered a second
one and now we both sleep like babies my
pillow products do not go flat you can
wash and dry them as many times as you
want they maintain their shape best of
all they are made right here in the
united states
if you don't have my pillow or you know
somebody who doesn't now is the time to
get one for a limited time my pillow is
offering their premium my pillows for
their
lowest price ever you can get a queen
size premium my pillow regularly 69.98
for only 29.98 it's a great price it's
40 bucks in savings
kings are only five bucks more now is
the time to buy not only are you getting
the lowest price ever they are the best
gifts ever if you want to get something
for dad for father's day that is
actually going to make his life markedly
better
get him a my pillow 29.98 for a queen
size premium my pillow go to
mypillow.com click on the radio listener
square use promo code daily wire you
will also get deep discounts on all my
pillow products including the giza dream
bed sheets the my pillow mattress topper
and my pillow towel sets or call
800-951-7163
and use promo code dailywire visit
mypillow.com now call 800-951-7163
okay so meanwhile you you have
as i say these people have declared
themselves the experts and yes they have
all the titles
they have they have all of the proper
credentialing but
the credentialing does not matter as
much as what you do with the
credentialing
if you got a degree from harvard medical
school but in your off hours you're
performing dr kavorkian
activities you're no longer acting as a
doctor and you don't deserve the title
if you're a journalist and in your off
hours or on your on hours you're just
pushing propaganda you're a propagandist
you're not a journalist
okay and this is why it is so insulting
to watch people conflate
processes with job descriptions
processes with titles so again
journalists hide behind the
cnn is very cnn that's a bunch of
journalists what they say can be trusted
or you could examine whether what they
are doing is journalism
this is why i distinguish journalism
from journalism right
my cynical take on journalism okay
same thing is true in science science is
a process
it is a process whereby you establish a
hypothesis and then that
that hypothesis is verifiable and
testable and you determine whether the
reality
comports or conflicts with that
particular hypothesis you see whether
the null hypothesis would come up with
the same result
it's an actual process just like
journalism is a process
so anything you do in life is a process
okay and that's why we judge people
based on their actions typically and not
based on their title
your title is not supposed to be a
shield it is not supposed to be a spear
it is supposed to be a description okay
and yet anthony fauci is now using his
title
as a sort of shield against his own
incompetence say anthony fouch has been
a terrible public servant
okay he has conflicted with himself over
and over and over again
he has lied to the american public and
then bragged about lying to the american
public whether it is
unmasking or whether it is on
vaccinations and their
and their efficacy he has changed his
standards with regards to the signs over
and over and over again
his emails show that he was warned of
the possibility of a wuhan lab like very
early on he not only
ignored it he actively downplayed it he
was emailing people talking about the
inefficacy of masks and then he shifted
his mind not based on shifting science
which he never really explained
he always says oh the science shifted
did it though show me the evidence that
the science shifted
like what actually shifted you can say
you got it wrong that's okay
but don't give me the science shifted
when there's not real evidence that the
science shifted
in any case dr fauci has really
he has drink he has drunk from the well
he's now drunk off the well i would say
of the of the titling and credentialism
that has taken over our society and you
the commoner you're supposed to just
ignore your own common sense and basic
judgment
and your ability to interpret fact in
favor of the experts the experts are
supposed to tell you what to do and dr
anthony voucher is an expert and so he
is insulted if you ask questions about
him
he is insulted if you ask him basic
questions like why did you change your
mind on every major topic over the
course of the last year from school
reopenings to masking to vaccinations
why here's dr anthony fauci pulling the
full
it's rare you get the full emperor
palpatine right it's pretty rare
seriously like in public life we get the
i am the senate it's pretty rare but
here you fully get
the emperor palpatine right you get
anthony fauci i am
the science okay here we go declaring
himself science dr anthony fauci the
greatest of all doctors outside of dr
jill biden
a lot of what you're seeing as attacks
on me
quite frankly are attacks on science
because all of the things that i have
spoken about consistently from the very
beginning
have been fundamentally based on science
sometimes those things were inconvenient
truths
for people and there was pushback
against me
so if you are trying to do you know get
at
me as a public health official and a
scientist
you're really attacking not only dr
anthony fauci you're attacking science
um nope nope
ah guys don't attack me i am the signs
okay it's what okay the utter
the utter dishonesty the other arrogance
tremendous arrogance of the supposed
public servants declaring himself the
science is insane
you can name off the top of your head
half a dozen instances where he just
lied
and admitted to lying right where he was
not representing the science again if he
didn't show his work
you didn't have to trust what he was
saying it's that simple science is
supposed to be
the most transparent of all fields
you're supposed to be able to understand
if you dedicate enough time
to an argument why people are making the
arguments they're making but dr anthony
fauci literally
i mean he's literally saying it if you
criticize him you're criticizing science
and this is the mentality of people who
believe they should run
your life this is the mentality of
people believe they should run every
aspect of your life they know better
than you you should trust them
they're the experts in just one second
we'll talk a little bit more about this
because it really is indicative
of how perverse this authoritarian view
of the world is we'll get to more of
this in just one second first
let's talk about the greatest father's
day gift i'm talking of course about
meat
i'm talking about the power of steak
okay so
omaha steaks a few years back they sent
me a kosher steak they've got it just
for me let me tell you
these people know what they are doing
summer is almost here that means
father's day is around the corner omaha
steaks is not just steak it is the
best steak of your life omaha steaks
delivers guaranteed quality and safety
with every single order
every order is flash frozen vacuum
sealed safely delivered in a cooler with
dry ice it stays ready to cook in the
freezer for months
go to omahasteaks.com type shapiro in
the search bar order to add the get out
and grill assortment i'll tell you what
this includes you ready for this
it includes 20 entrees guaranteed to
love they've got ultra juicy burgers
plum chicken breasts sides desserts four
10 ounce butchers cut new york strips
the strips are aged for 30 days
and tell you the aging process means
tender juicy delicious steak
get four free new york strip burgers
with your order as well
visit omahastakes.com keyword shapiro
get dad the get out and grill assortment
plus four free new york strip burgers
today
send dad more than just a gift send him
an experience he will love and can share
with you that is omahastakes.com
keyword shapiro to get started today
okay so again i cannot express
how perverse it is that dr anthony fauci
is now conflating his
himself right his own title with the
science it's insane
it's insane right and it is it is
perversely authoritarian
when somebody says you cannot criticize
me because you are then criticizing
my title and my title is the science
who made him king seriously who died and
made anthony fouchy king of science
i don't understand how this works he
could not even answer basic questions
about why he was masking after being
vaccinated
he couldn't answer those questions he
could not answer basic questions
about whether the united states had
passed through funding via eco health
alliance to the wuhan lab which was
performing gain and function research
he switched his opinion by the way on
the lab leak theory as to whether it was
important to check out
or not he lied openly and then bragged
about it with regard to masking and yet
he is the science
these people do not deserve one iota of
your trust not
one they need to prove it to you trust
is earned
trust does not come along with the title
okay the title just means you spent time
in school well congratulations
that does not mean that you are going to
be transparent or honest
and we're willing to give you the
benefit of the doubt i gave i anthony
fauci the benefit of the doubt for
months
and then i didn't anymore because he had
not earned it he had lost the benefit
of the doubt but the media again your
experts
the people you're supposed to trust
because here's the thing in
when you live in a complex society with
a lot of interlocking parts there has to
be a certain level of baseline trust in
other people
in order for you to function in your
daily life right you got to get your car
fixed that means you got to trust your
mechanic
you got to go to the grocery store you
didn't pick that food yourself you got
to trust the farmers you got to trust
the people who brought the food to the
store you have to trust the people
who are charging you for the food that
they didn't poison it and there's all
sorts of people you got to trust in the
chain
but the reason that you end up trusting
people in a market system is because of
repeatability
okay the reason that markets tend to
generate seriously property rights and
markets tend to generate higher levels
of trust in society why
because you have repeat transactions
with people over and over
the reason you can trust the grocery
store is because all your friends went
there and they didn't die
and you can go there over and over and
over again okay well
all of us went to the dr fauci store for
a year and it turns out
that he was not being honest and now
he's declaring that based on his title
we are supposed to trust him
not based on the repeat repeatability of
the trust
relationship okay the same thing is true
with regards to the journalism
experts among us they declare themselves
the experts because they went to nyu
school of journalism ooh
or because they work at cnn the most
trusted name in news
according to whom right and then they
say well you know what if you don't
trust us it's because you deny the power
of journalism
if donald trump declared you guys the
fake news because it turns out that half
the time what you guys do is just
express your own opinion and push
narratives that are false well then he
must be conflicting with journalism as
an institution
with the free press as an institution
this is a fundamental misunderstanding
of how human action works you ought to
be trusted when you are trustworthy and
you earn
trust with repeated acts of honesty you
do not gain trust by dint of being an
expert
there's been a great mix up in our
society that if you have a semi-high iq
you ought to be trusted because you know
things or because you are smart
i don't trust you guys to run a popsicle
stand i don't care what your iq is
if you can't prove to me you can run a
popsicle stand you don't deserve to run
the damn popsicle stand but all of
democratic governance
is rooted in this idea that because
these people are smarter
and wiser than you on a personal level
they know your business better than you
this is true in everything from
economics to science
you should trust anthony fauci even if
he's lying to you because he knows
what's best to you
for you and therefore he can tell you
platonic lies
you should trust joe biden with your
money even though he's a dundering old
fool you should trust joe biden with
your money
why well because he's probably smarter
than you i mean after all he was elected
president of the united states
he's an expert stop trusting people who
declare themselves
experts they don't know more about your
own life than you do
they don't which is why you should be
assessing risk in your own life
and you should be assessing who is
trustworthy in these fields
you have a brain use it i'm not
suggesting that you don't trust
people who have earned your trust i'm
not suggesting you shouldn't give people
the benefit of the doubt who originally
have the titles because they do know
more than you with regard to science but
once they have proved
over and over again they're not
trustworthy they don't get to call on
their title
to support the lies that they tell you
it really is quite gross by the way dr
anthony thatch at the same time he's
telling you that attacking him is
attacking the science he continues to
downplay
the chinese lab league theory like today
he continues to do it
why would the chinese want to make a
virus that equally
kills them as kills other people
so that's the reason why when you talk
about that's really way out there and
like off the wall you know off the chart
the other one is were they there working
with something in which they made
somehow manipulating the virus and then
it leaked out
certainly that's a possibility nothing
that we've seen
okay nothing that we've seen support
except for you know some of the actual
science
and the fact that there are only three
sites on earth where they manipulate
back coronal viruses and one of them is
a muhan
so yeah there are a few indicators there
but i love how he's setting up this
straw man
that the chinese purposely weaponized
the virus then released it that's not an
argument that's been made by virtually
anybody
with any sort of credibility okay but
again
once people declare themselves experts
on things you're supposed to listen to
them even if what they are spewing is
absolute horse manure even if what they
are spewing is the flatulence that comes
from the asses of cows you're supposed
to believe them
so long as it is given the imprimatur of
science
they use they use the titles as a cudgel
that is what they do
this is why for example you have an
article in the journal of american
cycle of the of the american
psychoanalytic association
titled on having whiteness by donald
moss now you may be asking yourself
what the hell does this have to do with
psychoanalysis well let donald moss tell
you
okay here is the abstract whiteness is a
condition one first acquires and then
one has
a malignant parasitic-like condition to
which white people
have a particular susceptibility the
condition is foundational
generating characteristic ways of being
in one's body in one's mind and in one's
world
parasitic whiteness renders its host
appetites voracious
insatiable perverse these deformed
appetites particularly target non-white
people
once established these appetites are
nearly impossible to eliminate
effective treatment consists of a
combination of psychic and social
historical interventions
such interventions can reasonably only
aim to reshape whiteness as infiltrated
appetites to reduce their intensity
redistribute their aims and occasionally
turn those aims toward the work of
reparation
when remembered and represented the
ravages wreaked by the chronic condition
can function either as a warning never
again or as temptation
great again it's the holocaust versus
donald trump
memorial memory memorialization alone
therefore is no guarantee against
regression there is not yet a permanent
cure
this is in a journal of supposed
psychoanalysis
okay again this is expertise in a title
being wielded as a club
understand that's just outright racism
okay this is just outright racism that
if you are white
you suffer from a condition known as
whiteness it is a parasitic condition
that destroys your ability to act
morally
or decently and makes you likely to
engage in a new holocaust
okay this is in the journal of american
psychoanalytic association
why would you possibly take that
institution seriously ever again
the same thing is true with regard to
things like the american medical
association that's supposed to be a
trustworthy body speaking about medicine
and yet they have said
in their journals things like you know
maybe we shouldn't put sex on birth
certificates anymore or we should put it
below
the top line because after all men who
declare themselves women are women that
is the most anti-scientific nonsense
ever but if you put it in the ama
journal well then it must be true
you have scientific american pushing
this nonsense and science the magazine
pushing this nonsense and then in the
name of science
you have people who are going to
directly target your life
in the name of the expertise remember
this is not rare okay this is common
once people declare themselves experts
with power they're willing to use that
power for just about anything in the
early 20th century
euthanasia and and eugenics were big
topics of discussion among the
intelligentsia because
it wasn't going to apply to them they
were they were the intelligentsia the
experts
eugenics which was a very popular table
talk topic
for the vast majority of intelligent
progressives in the early 20th century
internationally when you have oliver
wendell holmes literally writing supreme
court decisions
in which he says that we should be
sterilizing
people who have down syndrome because
quote unquote three generations of
imbeciles is enough that is in a direct
supreme court decision
buck versus bell hey that that mentality
that the experts ought to run things and
they know what's best for you up to and
including whether you should be able to
reproduce
how you should raise your children okay
that mentality is not only alive and
well it is thriving
it is thriving they shut down every
business in america
based on people with doctor in front of
their name telling you stuff that was
not scientific
they told you over and over in the media
because again these are your expert
journalists
they told you in the media that you were
at serious risk of dying if you were 20
years old and you got covered and it
wasn't true it was a lie
the statistics on death by covid for
people who were 20 years old were very
very very low and for
people under the 18 basically
non-existent to date
277 people under the age of 18 have died
in the united states of covid
277 in a country of 330
million people and now we are told by
the experts
that if you are two to five years old we
should be working on getting you back
it's high priority you have to have the
vaccine for two to five years
old maybe you shouldn't maybe you
shouldn't but you know what i'd like a
great scientific argument that's what i
would like
i haven't heard one yet anytime like
seriously bring it
i'm ready to hear it i'm super pro
vaccination but i want to know
where you are getting your info i want
to know why are you making the arguments
you're making
the history of people declaring
themselves experts and then controlling
people top down
that's funny the same secular
authorities who do it now they are just
a woke priesthood they are a secular
priesthood
they started off as just an atheistic
secular priesthood in the early 20th
century
and now it's a secular woke priesthood
which is even worse because now it's
like a pagan priesthood
at least they used to pretend that they
were speaking in the name of science now
they've merged science with wokeness
such that you get articles that are
blatant racism in the middle of jur
in the middle of scientific journals
okay in just a second i'm going to tell
you how they're going to
i mean really they're going to use the
expertise to come after your children
talk about that in just one second first
let us talk about
how you protect yourself against
predations against
people who are coming after you
personally people who are going to
threaten your safety
so owning a firearm is great but it's
really not enough if somebody breaks
into your house god forbid and they're
coming to do your harm
i'll tell you another thing you really
should have and that is body armor
i would highly recommend you to check
out ar 500 armor they have loadouts
designed
for everyone whether you need a
concealable vest for daily use a plate
carrier for the range or a fully
equipped setup for the worst case
scenario
our friends at ar500 armor have made
buying body armor easy approachable and
affordable
if you're unsure of what type of armor
you're needing or you just need some
pointers based on your needs they have
you covered
ar500 armor has multiple packages
pre-built for people just like you
and simplifies the entire process of
purchasing armor they have their
independence day sale going on right now
you can have your order in before the
fourth of july
these sales are up to 50 off select
products get them while they last
they have rifle rated bundles starting
as low as 99 bucks go to air 500 armor
dot com slash ben see all their
promotions and special pricing right now
you can use code ben for 20
off anything else in their entire store
best of all they've put together some
packages specifically
for my listeners here at the daily wire
there's something for everyone at ar500
armor.com
go check them out right now air 500
armor dot com ben use code ben
at checkout for 20 off i know these
folks they share your values ar500
armor.com
use code ben at checkout for 20 off
already in just one second
we're gonna get to science being used as
a cudgel against parents
first it's no secret the amount of
content we are putting out is growing
rapidly both in terms of numbers and in
terms of quality
we've got quality we've got quantity
tons of new stuff from our new
investigative journalism to our sports
column to my own
fact-filled podcast there's a lot to see
here and read even the most avid daily
where member would be hard-pressed to
keep up don't worry since we think of
everything we have a solution for you
you can now find all of the conservative
content you love and you need wherever
you are all on that daily wire app
even if you are not a daily wire
subscriber you will be the first to know
what's trending with mobile
notifications for the latest news and
all your favorite content
only a touch away so download the daily
wire app stay up to speed with the
freshest conservative voices around
no matter where you are you're listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in radio show in
the nation
[Music]
okay so when people say that the experts
should run your life the
the experts after all one thing you
should note here is that
they will run your life i mean they will
come after everything you hold dear
including your kids
there's a great piece by abigail
schreier in city journal today
which is the journal of the manhattan
institute about
the rules in the city of seattle she
writes a story about this guy named
ahmed a pakistani immigrant faithful
muslim until recently a financial
consultant in seattle's high-tech sector
apparently he in october 2020 he and his
wife had checked their 16 year old son
in seattle's children's hospital for
credible threats of suicide
and now ahmed was worried that the white
coats who had gently admitted his sons
of their care would refuse to return him
they sent an email to us you know you
should take your daughter to the gender
clinic
so apparently his kid was 16 had autism
got depressed was suicidal so they
checked him in
okay the lockdowns hit and this meant
that he couldn't visit his son so the
white coats started talking to this 16
year old autistic kid
and the six-year-old autistic kid
declared a suicidal autistic kid
declared
that he was gender dysphoric the experts
refused to release the kid to the
parents
unless the parents lied and said they're
gonna take him to the gender clinic
hey this sort this is what happens when
you let the experts run things
they don't know what they purport to
know but they don't know what they don't
know
and so they continue to promote stuff
that is not science that is just
garbage apparently ahmed assured
seattle's children's hospital he would
take us under a general clinic and
commence in sudden
transition from male to female instead
he took his son home
quit his job and moved his family of
four out of washington
it's a year later it turns out that his
son is not gender dysphoric it was just
the state coming after his kid
by the way in the state of washington
kids can start receiving
gender dysphoric treatment at the age of
13 without parental consent
because the experts say so the experts
based on nothing
based on nothing why would you let these
morons run your life why would you let
them make
all the rules it's dangerous to let them
make all the rules
and what's amazing about this is is
their stupidity is on display for all to
see
all the time okay kamala harris is
probably going to end up
as the successor to joe biden if joe
biden makes it through his first term
she's going to run in 2024 if he doesn't
make it through his first term she'll be
president of the united states
and she is terrible at this she's an
idiot kamala harris does not know things
she doesn't care about things
somehow she's been elevated to a
position of public power where we're
supposed to believe that she knows how
to run things
okay so you'll remember just a couple of
days ago she was asked about going down
to the border and she started cackling
like a hyena for no reason at all
well now it turns out even the cnn is
even the white house is disappointed
in kamala harris here's cnn explaining
vice president kamala harris back in the
united states this morning after a trip
to guatemala and mexico her first
foreign trip as vice president
this morning we're told that some of
what she said on the trip
her answers to questions maybe even
obvious questions
those answers have white house insiders
perplexed
i mean truly it is an amazing amazing
thing right but that but that is
going to run everything
right this is what people want
apparently people want these morons to
run
i do not understand for the life of me i
can watch dr anthony fauci's performance
over the last year or andrew cuomo's
performance over the last year or phil
murphy's performance over the last year
or gavin newsom's performance over the
last year and save yourself i need these
people to have more power over my life i
don't know how you watch the members of
the media lie to you consistently and
say i definitely am good
i know i know that what they're saying
about my industry is untrue because i
know my industry but probably if i
switch three pages over they probably
know more about that industry
or maybe they don't or maybe they don't
okay again they're showing you every day
who they are
they're showing you every day how
incompetent they are that they are not
experts in anything
they can't even operate like basic
systems
evidence more today okay the prices have
now jumped five percent in may
okay remember at that time when we were
told that inflation would not kick in
even if you just inject trillions of
dollars into the economy
i mean well encourage people not to stay
home remember that time
well now it turns out that when you have
more dollars chasing less product
you end up with inflation according to
rachel siegel over the washington post
prices were up by five percent in may
compared with a year ago
the largest increase since the great
recession continuing a steady climate
inflation even as policymakers insist on
staying the course
data released thursday by the bureau of
labor statistics showed prices rose
0.6 in the past month alone policymakers
have predicted prices will rise over the
coming months
especially compared to a year ago when
the economy was still reeling from the
pandemic shutdowns
now here is the problem inflation will
continue if you continue to depress
the labor market by telling people not
to work
now it's possible that inflation levels
off but you're still sucking so much
money out of the economy
that people don't have money to invest
that you are redistributing from people
who know how to invest in how to create
a product to a bunch of morons at the
top of government
the same morons who are declaring that
inflation is no problem for you as they
devalue your savings
these are the same idiots who are going
to be running the economy a year from
now
hey why why would you trust them i don't
understand
joe biden you trust this guy to run the
world seriously
it's amazing all the same people on the
left are like donald trump has too much
power he's an authoritarian why would
you trust this bumbling idiot
to run the world okay i can ask the same
question about joe biden because he is a
bumbling
and here is my question why would you
want any of these people to run the
world
any of them what if we don't give them
power how's that how about that how
about we go back to a system
where the president doesn't have
unending power where the executive
branch
doesn't run every aspect of your life
and then you don't have to care
then you don't have to care you know why
people don't care about the local dog
catcher's race
because unless you need to you need a
dog caught you don't actually care it
doesn't affect your life
but you want to give more power to the
president because you think that he is
going to weaponize on behalf of your
point of view
instead he's just going to a crew power
in the institution and then somebody
don't like he'll take over
and then we'll just have a fight about
that but it's amazing we're supposed to
trust joe biden
and the media again your journalism
experts they want you to trust joe biden
article in the washington post today joe
biden is overseas he's over in england
and now says the washington post he is
such an expert i mean my goodness
he's so good at this i love this
here's how they describe joe biden not
since george h.w bush has a president
taking office with such long experience
in foreign affairs
biden came to the senate in 1973 chaired
the foreign relations committee asked
his appointment on various global issues
when he was barack obama's vice
president
at every stop in the coming week from
scenic carbus bay in britain's coastal
cornwall district to brussels in geneva
biden will seek to leverage his personal
familiarity with fellow leaders
in an effort to re-establish american
engagement abroad
jen sackey said he's been getting ready
for 50 years yes but he's been wrong for
50 years he hasn't been right on a
single foreign policy issue
his entire career also he is adult
okay yesterday here is joe biden
explaining that he keeps forgetting that
he is president
yes we know sir we're aware
and sydney you're 14 years old
when i was 14 if you please at ease
i keep forgetting i'm president yeah we
know we know sir
jill had to tell joe to pay attention in
the middle of his speech
you know you can sit down
i don't want you to stand through it
joe pay attention oh my god
oh my god by the way joe biden and we're
now just rerunning the woodrow wilson
administration edith is running the show
apparently because joe biden literally
tweeted out yesterday
a picture of herself sitting i guess
this is in
joe biden's office on air force one
sitting and reading a briefing book
prepping for the g7 who elected jill
biden
who i don't understand if laura bush had
done this people be like what the f
she's a librarian why should what
huh if melania had done this people have
been like wait a second she was a model
like what are you huh why
no one elected jill biden but apparently
joel biden is president of the united
states now
sitting there prepping for the g what is
her job at the g7 seriously
is she making economic policy now this
genius community college professor
who wrote apparently the world's
greatest dissertation doctor joe biden
the greatest
these are the experts she has the title
she's a doctor she should run the g7
clearly we didn't elect her she has no
background in any of this stuff but you
know what
it's all good probably she'll be good
she has a doctor in front of her name
after all i mean that's that's the thing
that really
really matters meanwhile edel joe is out
there telling the military that the
greatest threat the military is going to
face is global warming
the greatest threat the what are they
going to do shoot the
shoot the sun what are you talking about
here is joe biden informing the military
that their great job is going to be
standing there like knut
trying to trying to hold back the ocean
go president biden go when i first
was elected vice president with
president obama
the military sat us down to let us know
what the greatest threats facing america
were the greatest physical threats
this is not a joke you know what the
joint chiefs told us the greatest threat
facing america was global warming
because there'll be significant
population movements
okay that's just fights over land
millions of people leaving
places because they're literally sinking
below the sea in indonesia okay this
this nonsense it's just garbage okay the
idea that you're gonna have millions of
people
who are in short order going to be
shifting population centers people have
been migrating for literally all of
human history
as the water levels gradually rise
presumably people will migrate away from
places that will be underwater but it's
not going to be day after tomorrow and
it's not going to be the us military
that's in charge of handling this this
is just insanity
don't when somebody declares they're an
expert like joe biden oh well the joint
chief said global warming is the big
issue
why these people should not control your
life you should control your life the
purpose of democracy is that you control
what happens
and granting these people more power is
a betrayal of the basic notion
of republican self-governance
self-governance
you govern yourself not the experts
not dr fauci he was not elected he is
not the king
not your journalist your journalism
masters who are not elected
you don't have to watch them and you
don't have to pay attention to them and
you are certainly allowed to
second-guess them
and not joe biden and not any other
politician even if you elected him
he was not elected to run your life he
was elected to protect your individual
rights that is the purpose of the
constitution of the united states
if the american people don't understand
that then we definitely have lost the
republic
a long time ago as it turns out alrighty
a little bit later today we'll be back
for an additional hour of the ben
shapiro show coming up soon
matt wall show airs at 1 30 p.m eastern
be sure to check it out over at
dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavel wydowsky
editing is by adam's psy events audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
on the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show